all right the last two years have been
difficult for teachers filled with both
tremendous obstacles and new discoveries
mary jane belliesa takes us to dusty
dickens elementary to highlight one
education one educators i should say
resiliency image down here to help us
compare second grade teacher tori law is
always up for a challenge she says it's
one of the best ways to maintain your
full potential she adds the past two
years as an elementary teacher we're not
only grinding but full of new goals you
know it's really a good opportunity for
me to be creative and to find fun and
exciting ways to you know inspire them
and encourage them and they soak up
everything
so it's just really cool to see them you
know grow principal carolyn king says
law's commitment and drive is inspiring
to see rory is an awesome teacher she is
an awesome leader on our campus we
actually hired tori she was a long-term
sub for her and she did such a great job
that we hired her permanently and it has
been such a joy to watch her grow
second grade is just
it's such a fun age you know they are
hilarious they say some of the craziest
things sometimes but you know they
always manage to put a smile on their
face loss says she knows the lasting
impressions a teacher can have on their
students it's what makes teaching
worthwhile
i really really want them to just have
that passion instilled in them too the
passion for learning perseverance just
keep going and i want them to maintain
that curious mind because if they stay
curious then they're always going to
want to learn more mary jane balliesa
live local now